So, I used to be one of those Muslim
women who were like, "I'm not a
feminist. We don't need feminism.
Feminism Islam gave us rights before
feminism. We just need Islam."
They had me. Like, they they got me.
They got me. They got me.
>> Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's why
Allah says,
You are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the graves. Brothers and
sisters, masid Norway, the one that we
built is looking to another masid around
the area of Norway. Subhan Allah. Where
there's so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masid is only
$500,000. And any donation that you give
will go towards your because when you
enter that grave, nobody's going to
remember you except Allah subhanaa tala.
So make it count, brothers and sisters,
and donate towards this message,
inshallah, a new project that's only
$500,000. And believe me, if every
single one of us give £1,10, £100,
£1,000, that's going to be something you
will never regret on your makama and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go, but your deeds and your
makama are not. Donate to the link
inshallah. Let's get to the video.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
it is your local misogynist Ali Da as
known as the Da Bros. And you know us
with the DA bros and the whole Dawa
scene. Corrupt individuals, you know,
like I said before, we always getting
caught out doing haram stuff. You know,
you name it, we've done it.
Alhamdulillah. Anyways, before I start
this video, guys, I'm sure the sister at
question here and many of them are going
to watch it. You know, some of them come
to my da go, you're a misogynist. I got
interesting sister. What? Can you name
me one thing? I've said misogynistic,
please.
And just, you know, I look at them and
like, you know, yeah, oh no, no, no,
sister. is can you just mention what is
it that said misogynistic and they're
like um I don't know I heard oh you
heard okay it all starts like this this
victim mentality of sisters they they
actually okay genuinely they have this
victim mentality of their and their
originist they are the victims and their
ex-husbands and men are the culprits so
sorry with all due respect sisters yes
and I'm not talking about all by the way
these are just like a couple of them yes
sadly there's a lot of sisters affected
by feminism but we're going to be
reacting to so many videos And the
reason why I wanted to do this video is
to show the danger. Yes. The danger of
women like them who are single mothers.
And I don't blame there are many single
mothers who are mah may Allah bless and
preserve them. I've been doing videos
about this 12 13 years ago. Biging up
single mothers. I'm not saying all of
them. I'm not saying all of them. Yes, a
lot of them, alhamdulillah, were married
to very tapped in the head men etc. But
in today's time, brothers and sisters,
we're dealing with a whole different
kind of woman. Whole different kind of
woman. And I'm not generalizing. We're
going to watch a video. And in this
videos, before I start, obviously I want
to give a little condition. Any ones
that are watching this and deems me to
be a misogynist, I am ready to delete my
YouTube channel, give £1,000 of my money
to you sisters. If you can prove and
show me one place that I have said
something misogynistic, one place,
thousand cash, and my YouTube is going
to get deleted, th bro, one of these D
bro is going to get rid of me in an
instant. If you can't and you never can
because I have done more for sisters and
speaking more for sisters than any of
sisters can ever in your life inshallah.
Yes, I've given a voice to the sisters
in the bit of truth show even if I had
people who have disagreed with okay many
people was one of a brother that
disagree with a lot of stuff that he
said. Yes. But because I had him on the
show so you know I'm so sorry the show
is for everybody but let's get on to the
video. So this is very interesting.
Yeah. This is why I say it is so
detrimental for women to get advice from
other women, specifically single mothers
like this sister. Yes. Okay. Let's watch
for ourel and let's see what is the
tantrum that she has because she's gone
on a tantrum. Let's see what it is. And
you can see she's so fixated. She's a a
single mother who's left her husband.
Why are you so obsessed with I genuinely
firstly we don't know his side of the
story. We don't know what kind of woman
you was. I don't know what kind of a man
he was. But the way you come out as if
you are the victim. How do I know you
you wasn't a narcissist, a manipulating,
gaslighting individual, how do I know
you was not the problem? How do I know?
I don't know if he was not the problem.
He may have been the problem, but you
come across and because you're more
vocal. We men, we don't talk. We hold it
in. Yes. Okay. Okay. So, because of
that, you act like you are the victim.
Here's the video in Let's watch the
first video, inshallah, guys, and let's
get straight into it because it gets
very, very interesting. And I'm sure
you're going to enjoy this video from a
misogynist like me.
>> So, I used to be one of those Muslim
women who were like, I'm not a feminist.
We don't need feminism. Feminism. Islam
gave us rights before feminism. We just
need Islam.
They had me. Like they they got me. They
got me. They got me. They got me. They
got me.
Deentering men from your dean. That is
something. Every everyone's talking
about decentering men. When you desent
men from Islam, when you desent men from
your dean,
they had me for a long time. They keep
you so they're so loud, so loud about
how feminism is so anti-Islamic.
Feminism has destroyed society.
Feminismah
Well, they completely hijacked Islam
with their misogyny completely.
>> I mean, they're right. There you go.
There you go. typical. They had me. They
had me. They had me. Okay. Like I even
believe like this here is a bit
masculine. Like I'll be honest with you.
Like what is this? Like as a woman, they
had me. I don't understand. And then at
the end, what is it? Misogyny. Close the
chapter. Anything. You know, feminism
again, there's a lot of things that are
in line with Islamic feminism. I've said
this in my university talks, wherever I
go when I speak to it. As Muslims, we
don't need feminism. Okay? Why do we
need to go if a man doesn't fear Allah?
If you're married to a man who doesn't
fear Allah, do you think he's going to
give a crap about a man a sorry, a woman
made law? Okay. a woman made law. No,
he's not. So that's in the angle. But
there's a lot of similarities between
feminism and Islam. Alhamdulillah, that
Islam gave the rights of the woman long
time ago before feminism were throwing
theelves in front of king's carts to get
get it, you know, on suicide missions.
So desenter, not just men, desenter men
and women. Your center should focus
should be Allah. If you center and bring
men to a level where you like, you know,
as if like you worship them, Allah will
humate with it. If you bring a woman to
a level where you worship them, Allah
will humate with that. So I agree with
the center men and women, you know, in
that instance. Let's go to the next
video in because it gets very
interesting, guys. Okay, I hope you guys
enjoyed the video guys. But before that,
please download the Salah Pro app.
Brothers and sisters, we are a charity.
All of our services on the app is for
free. Free kibla finder, no ads, free
salah reminders, encourages to pray,
tells you salah times. You can book a
salah instructor, a Quran instructor.
You can order a guided prayer map for
absolutely free if you want to learn how
to pray salah. Videos on how to pray
salah, salah hubs, and many, many more.
Brothers and sisters, we are not an app
that shares your information with third
parties. All of our services on the app
is for free. Download it now in enjoy
guys. Let's go back to the video.
>> It feels a little fake and gay. Got to
tell you guys, it feels a little fake
and gay and there will be no fakeness
and no gayness.
>> Okay, good. So, you can see what we're
dealing with here. Okay. Um, so it it
feels gay that they're a hyper masculine
da guy. So, you see, they see that as a
threat. Masculinity. When we come and
tell the brothers, "Brother, train, look
after your family, you're the protector,
you're the threat to them. Masculinity
is only a threat to a woman who has
masculine traits. A feminine woman will
see that nothing but as as goodness.
Like do we ever talk about toxic
femininity? What does toxic masculinity?
What does that mean? Like for example,
you know, one to provide for his family,
protect his family, look after his
family, be the protector and provider,
someone who leads his family, who has a
final say in a marriage. Oh, am I being
misogynistic now? Oh, am I controlling
my wife? Yes, in my marriage, I have the
last say. Yeah. Oh, you feel sorry for
my wife. Oh, that's deep, man. I'm so
sorry, Mrs. misogynistic single uh uh
single uh woman that you're going to
stay single for the rest of your life.
What do you deem that? So now it's gay.
Look at the word she it's gay cuz da
bros what is it? Hyper masculine da
bros. What does that mean? Let's carry
on. It gets interesting guys. I just
really it really gets interesting. The
reason I'm doing this video is because
woman like her who was a single mother
wants misery likes company. Yes. They
want other women to be single. And
that's the reason why you can see which
we're going to go through some hadiths
and let's see how misogynistic the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam was.
Okay, forget us. We are misogynistic da
bro. Okay, we're going to get there in.
And I would love for this sister to tell
me and reply like not to me. This hadith
that I'm going to mention, are they
misogynist? Like is the protest
misogynist? Let's carry on.
I'll be honest with you, this kind of
reaction. Okay, somebody commented
saying you're going to be a single
mother forever. And look, we again,
look, you're our sister. I don't want
you to be single forever. You need a
masculine man, but you need to be in a
feminine energy. If you're moving
masculine, yes, with your body language
and the way you're behaving and the way
you're talking, I'll be honest with you,
I don't know a a brother who's saying
who's on his dean, which we're going to
come to. By the way, you advising people
that you do not want someone on the
dean, which I was mind by the way. Yes.
Okay. If you behave like this, sister,
you're going to be single for the rest
of your life. I'm I do not want any sane
man in his head who's a man who fears
God to be with someone like you with all
due respect. And I don't wish that. I
wish you the best that a good man who
fears God. Like we're going to come to
you talking about your husband or
apparently he was religious or whatever.
I don't know what you mean by that.
Okay. Now you're warning against you're
basically saying you will never marry a
man that he's on his dean. You're
tapped. With all due respect, sister,
you are tapped. If you if that's what
you're saying, wa you've gone. It seems
like you're so traumatized. You're so
traumatized. You don't even know what
you're talking about. You don't even
know what you're talking about. Okay.
This one is
>> icon. She's a legend and she is the mom.
>> Okay. Interesting. Look. Look at the
pictures. She's icon. She's a legend. M,
you know, feminism, but brilliant. Look
what she's done. And nothing terrifies
them more than a woman learning her
worth and leaving them. So they try to
demo demonize it. This is what I'm
doing. I'm demonized. I'm so threatened
by, you know, you destroying your
marriage or whatever reason they got.
We're so threatened by it. And he says
those divorce papers are a proof of your
self worth. Look how disgusting this is.
You are out there encouraging divorce.
Something that is hated. Yes. Disliked.
Of course, it's halal out there. Why?
And who's it coming from? A single
mother. You are telling us about oh go
it's it's what it's divorce are proof of
your self worth. What a irresponsible
person you are. Well irresponsible
person you are. Let's go to the next
video.
Amazing. Got another brilliant advice
from the sister. Yes. And by the way
with all your respect I'm not trying to
disrespectful with those eyelashes that
you have which I'll be honest with you.
Do you like like I don't mean to be
disrespectful, sister, but do you think
that looks attractive? Like, oh, let me
guess. Oh, brother, lower your gaze. Oh,
my bad. My bad. You know, when your
videos popped up, yeah, with fully
makeup and caked up. Yes. Not that you
should not wear makeup and be public and
cake yourself. No, no, it's my fault
that you popped up on my screen and I
shouldn't have been like, you know, what
is those eyelashes? With all due
respect, what is those eyelashes? And
here what she says, beauty tip. Have
that baby and leave. What an amazing
advice. A responsible advice from a
single mother advising other Muslim
women. Have that baby and leave.
Amazing, beautiful advice. Well, she
just proves my point. Furthermore, do
not go to other women like her. Wallah,
she will destroy your marriage. Misery
loves company. Okay, she seems still
traumatized and all she's talking about
is divorce, divorce, divorce, divorce.
And it gets worse. Check this next one
out.
Somebody s says, "So what do you rather
then a man who's not on his deed?"
Listen carefully to what she says, guys.
I was like, "No, you cannot drop that
law." No, no, no, no. Check this out.
>> Absolutely.
Absolutely. Um I have no desire to be
the men again.
>> Sorry, sister. With all your respect, I
don't know which man would want to be
with you. She go, "Oh, I don't have
desire to be with a man." Okay, she's
saying basically absolutely that I do
not want to be with a man who's on his
dean.
>> Um, but if I don't know, I smacked my
head really hard one day and I decided
to get married.
>> Sister, I think you already smacked your
head somewhere already. I think that
statement, there's more of a chance you
smacked your head before you've done the
video, then you are going to smack it
after you've done the video.
>> Um, absolutely.
>> Absolutely. Let me put this into
perspective, guys. There's two options
about your ex because we don't know
nothing about him. He hasn't said
nothing. And if he's watching this, bro,
reach out to me. Firstly, I want to know
because I don't I'm not anybody's side
here, but is she even allowing you to
see your child? Yes. Because we know
there are some evil scum dirt bag of
sisters out there. I'll say it to their
faces who use the kids and it's a major
sin in Islam to not show the kids. It's
vice versa. If a husband was doing the
same, I would say the same thing.
Firstly, are you seeing the children,
which number one number two, she's so
hostile against religious people. That's
why she brings us da bros. Bro, what are
you talking about? Da bros. What are you
on about? like she's keep attacking us.
She's got this vengeance. She's scorned
after da guys for what? What's she
looking for? She's looking for a slip
up. Okay. So, she's saying she doesn't
she would not ever go for someone who's
on his deed.
Wow. So, I I put it in two perspectives.
Number one, he was married to a man who
deemed religious. Yes. And there are
brothers who do this. By the way, I
advise sisters do not marry a man who's
over like he looks religious. He sounds
religious, but the things he's saying is
not permissible. Oh, you can't go to
here or you can't like like these weird
rules because he's insecure within
himself like oh you can't go there or
you can't go and study you can't hold on
a second bro shut the hell up man
brother with all due respect there was a
case that came to me I was shocked yeah
so there's either one situation that you
was married to a brother who was super
religious and I'm looking and I'm
thinking if you was dressed up how you
was and with eyelashes and this that I
don't know what religious brother would
have married you with all your due
respect number two you was married to a
brother who was on his dean like I for I
don't know. And this is scenarios that
happen. Sisters think they want
religious man. You don't want religious
man. You can't deal with a religious man
because religious man they don't mess
around. Yes. A religious man is somebody
who has boundaries, who is secure in the
self, who is masculine. Okay. Who has
comes to you and with traditional values
and you in your feministic masculine
energy don't like that because when it
tells you those eyelashes can fly, you
say, "You can't tell me what to do.
You're not wearing lipstick. You can't
tell me what to do. Um, you're not
dressing up like that. you can't tell me
what to do. Um, I am the protector and
provider, etc. You can't tell me. So,
when they're dealing with someone like
yourself, I'm assuming most likely, I
don't know, with this energy that you're
showing, that religious brother's
thinking, brother Bis, this is the type
of woman that I married. So, that sister
or for example, he wants to, God forbid,
want to get married again. Oh, hell
break loose. Even if he's the protector,
provider, good bar, emotionally
intelligent who shows his shows love a
genuine man that takes care. The moment
you mention you want to get married
again in a Islamic way. Nada brother,
you are finished. You become what? Never
marry a religious guy. So Islamically in
the sight of Allah, has he done
something wrong? No. But you have
reduced him down to what? Religious men
are bad. Why are they bad? Because they
come with traditional values that's
Islamic and I can't deal with them
because I've been brainwashed with
feminism and that's why I'm kicking
back. The issue is not with the
religious man. The issue is with
yourself. Not just you. A lot of
sisters. That's the issue. That's why
you guys are not ready for a religious
man. Go marry a jah who looks a bit
religious. Who go and cheat on you with
side chicks and girlfriends and mish
left right center. Okay. Who doesn't
remind you to pray salah, who doesn't
read Quran, who doesn't tell you
anything. And then you say, "Yeah, I
want that kind of man who looks
religious." You're not ready for a
religious man. And when a genuine
religious man comes into your life, you
can't deal with it because you don't
want that. You're not about that life.
You want your nails done every week. You
want to go on holidays. you want to have
fine dining and this that and you just
want someone that wears a phobe and
looks good. You don't want a religious
man. So I agree with that in that sense
like Allah says in the Quran bad men are
for bad women. Let this go talking about
I'm not talking equating that to the
sister here at all. Alhamdulillah. Yeah.
What I'm saying is this. You can see
what kind of a woman you are with all
due respect sister to come and if I came
and said nah I'm not I don't want a a
woman in a in a dean. It shows what kind
of a man I am. A man like me I would say
for example if I'm not practicing that I
don't want a woman in a dem it doesn't
interest me I don't have any shared
values it shows where you are at life
subh okay it very shows it might be that
you was married to a very good man yes
that you didn't understand his value it
can be or it can be a viol could be an
oppressor for that matter so this is
absolutely disgusting let's go to the
next video
>> happened to me last year I exposed a
predator and they turned me into a
heretic the men who turn these
conversations into but it's not all us
men don't generalize it's not all trust
our bros. They are worse than the
abusers themselves. Let me explain why.
>> Interesting. When we come and say don't
generalize, it's not us. We are the
problem. Interesting. Let's carry on.
>> Abusers rely on silence, denial, and
minimization to continue their harm.
>> Interesting. I like this. I like the way
she broke it down, those terminologies,
etc. She's dissected it, guys. Woo.
Let's carry on. So these men who derail
the conversation by centering
themselves, they become complicit
enablers.
>> Interesting. Just by saying we shouldn't
generalize because that's what a lot of
people do with us Muslims and we're
terrorists. No, no, no, no. We are doing
this because we are trying to justify
it. The abuse and you know all these men
for some odd reason are narcissist
abusers and gaslight users. Never the
woman. It's always these men. They are
reinforcing the very structures that
protects abusers and stops survivors
from speaking out. This is exactly what
happened to me last year. I exposed a
predator and they turned me into a
heretic.
>> She exposed an abuser. Who's the abuser?
A brother who proposed to her for a
second marriage etc. Yes. Some things he
said was distasteful and the way he went
about it was distasteful 100%. Did he
call you to haram? Did he say let's
commit zena? Did he say no? No, it was a
marriage. That's an Islamically valid
marriage which of course it was
distasteful and like I I even personally
told him myself but no no no no no no no
no no no no no no but you know she's
sorry abuser how to become an abuser
with all your due respect on what
paradigm but let's carry on
>> instead of addressing the actual
situation they took that as a chance to
say it's not all men I got attacked and
threatened and silenced by the good ones
why to remind us women that if we dare
try to expose if we dare try to speak up
against. If we dare try to empower each
other, we will be met with so much
backlash. It's better just to keep
quiet.
>> Interesting. I don't remember any time
or anyone doing a video saying you
should not talk about it because I'll be
honest with you, I've done videos
warning sisters long time ago about
certain men who are use their religious
powers. So, sister, you're new to this.
I've been talking about this a long time
ago. Long time ago. So, this nothing
new. You're not a victim. With all due
respect, you are not the victim. Stop
playing the victim game. Okay? Instead
of accepting and acknowledging and
speaking against what happened, they
chose to deny and deflect, which is what
creates the environment that makes abuse
possible. And if you as a man truly
can't see what's happening right in
front of your face, it's because you're
a part of the problem.
>> Okay. Interesting. So, we should come
and generalize everybody. We should come
and say, it's like me saying every
hijabi woman is like her. Do not marry
hijabis. Every hijabi is like that.
Every Muslim woman is like that. Can you
imagine me coming and making massive
bold statements and saying every hijabi
is that do not marry? What are you on
about? Are you okay? You're basically
saying that they should generalize all
men. All men are predators. All men are
this that. Who told you respect? I'm so
sorry. I'm so sorry. Like if you're
going to talk about that, for example,
bring evidence from the Quran. You have
none. I'll give you some inshallah and
you can maybe mention some of these.
Okay. All right. Let's go. Let's see.
Misogyny. Let's see. Is the prophet
sallallam. Okay. The prophet narrated by
Abbas and I'll end on this video like
this. Inshallah. Yeah. The prophetam
said, "I was shown the hellfire." Oh,
now this is what she said. Oh, here we
go. It's a reality. And the majority of
the dwellers of were women who were
ungrateful. It was asked, "Do they
disbelieve in Allah? Are they ungrateful
to Allah?" He replied, "They are
ungrateful to their husbands and are
ungrateful for the favors and the good
childhood deeds done to them. If he was
always being good, benevolent to one of
them, and she sees something in front of
her like in in you, not of her like him,
she will say, "What? I have never
received any good from you. With all due
respect, sister, I'm a married man.
Okay? And there are many married men
that we know. Okay? Women have this in
their nature. Now, do they mean it? No.
But imagine as a man, I go to my wife,
alhamdulillah, may Allah bless and
preserve her, and I say, "I've seen no
good in you." That's a bold statement.
Now, the thing is, what is the prophetam
telling us that this is in the nature of
a woman? The way she behaves, she's in
gratitude. You go to I've spoken to
non-Muslim men some of them they hear
this and go whoa he's definitely the
best of Allah he's best the best of god
okay this shows you what this the
prophetam gave solution the prophet were
not dealing with feministic masculine
woman like you with all you respect the
unsidian woman the woman who listen to
this they looked for solution okay they
understood okay that's a shortcoming in
ours we should be more grateful okay is
the prophet a misogynist I would not be
surprised if they said yes so narrated
by
okay I went to and saw that the people
were prostrating themselves before a sat
of theirs. So I said the messenger of
Allah has most right to have prostration
made before him. When I came to the
prophetam I said I went to and saw them
prostrating themselves before a sat. I
don't know what that means of theirs.
But you have more right measure of Allah
to have people prostrating themselves
before you. He said tell me if you were
to pass by my grave would you proate
yourself before it? I said no. He then
said do not do so. If I were to command
Oh my gosh. They're going to have a fit
now. They're going to rip their hair
out. Bro, these Muslim feminists are
going to rip their hair out. Command
anyone to prostrate before another one.
I would have commanded the woman, the
wife, to prostrate themselves before the
husband because of the special right
over them. Now, am I a misogynist? Am I
a woman hater? I got three daughters. I
have a wife. I have a brother.
No. This is a reality.
W men, we have a responsibility. It's
not a perk. It's a responsibility that
we have one d like Allah says in the
Quran. We have a d over woman. We are
your full-time bodyguard. We are ready
to die and put our life on the line for
you. We are the protector and provider
for you. Okay? We have to lead you
because you have emotional imbalance. If
Allah's created, you're not blamew
worthy. This is how Allah subhana wa
tala has created you. And if you have
those deficiencies, okay, which is
absolutely normal because as men, we
have the deficiencies. Allah tells in
the Quran, if you turn your back in
warfare, it's made you sit in a
hellfire. Brother, the natural thing to
do in war is sometimes turn your back.
We are threatened with it. So why?
Because Allah knows we can have
weaknesses in the battlefield. It's our
deficiency. We can be scared. So
therefore, Allah gives us a reminder. We
don't have a fit over it. So let's go to
the next hadith. Now the prophetam said,
"Isn't the witness of a woman equal to
half of the man?" The woman said, "Yes."
He said, "This is because of the
deficiency." Even though the word some
say it's not a correct word, deficiency
of a woman's mind, but one thing that's
clear and it talks about the the
religion is because of the menstrual
cycle. This is not something you're
blame worthy because if you connect
hadith together the the deficiency of
the mind and the deficient of the
religion the religion is not the woman's
fault if she's an amenist. So surely
then that means the scholars say even
that it's not they're not blamew worthy
of it. It just shows that they they in
that area that is not their expertise
when it comes to finances or certain
specific things but which shows what if
you're created in that delicate way you
need a man to protect you guard you and
look after you. That's why the prophetam
said, "If I was to ask anyone to
prostrate to anybody, it will be the the
woman to the husband because of his
right. He's out there providing and
protecting for you and dealing with an
ungrateful Oh gosh, how many men are
dealing with ungrateful woman?" Okay.
And look look at the rewards. Abu Hur
reported that wasallam said, "If a woman
prays her five prayers, fast the month
of Ramadan, guards her chastity and
obeys her husband, have you ever come
across a hadith that says the opposite?
If a man does d and her her his wife is
pleased with her, yes, you never find
it. It says she will enter paradise from
any gate wishes. That is such an amazing
reward. Why? Because it shows the
responsibility of a man. It's not a
perk. It's a responsibility. That's the
reason why you don't see the opposite
hadiths pertaining to a woman. You don't
it doesn't mean you don't treat your
wife well. Okay?
And this one like for example Al Hussein
Iban reported his aunt came to pro
prophet peace be upon him with a need.
And when she finished explaining her
need the prophet said to her do you have
a husband? She said yes. The prophet
said how are you with him? She said she
didn't say how is he with you said how
are you with him? She said I do not
neglect him unless I am unable. The
prophet said look to look to yourself
regarding him verily he is your paradise
or hellfire. Is he a misogynist? Is he a
misogynist? Our
religion is clear. A man, of course, we
have to look after our wives. Allah,
take care of them because when they're
pregnant, they're vulnerable. Yes, when
they're on their menes, yes, they have
hormonal imbalances. They say things,
man. The prophetam's wife smash plays in
front of him. But look how the prophetam
dealt with it gracefully. He said, "Your
mother's upset. We have to excel to be
be like that, brothers. We take each
other's account, but you women don't
take each other account. You play a
victim mentality. You exor always
narcissist, beds, gaslighters. Get out
of here. With all due respect, to come
and say all the time the men are the
fault is nonsense. The reason I'm doing
this video is guys to say women like
this are home wreckers. Destroy us.
You're a single mother. Fix your act.
Stop acting masculine. Yes. Okay. Islam
has given you rights. Turn back to your
dean. Okay. If the more as much time
that you focus on your eyelashes, your
makeup sister, if you gave some of that
effort effort to studying your religion,
you wouldn't be going out saying I'm
never going to marry a man on his dean.
What kind of statement is that? Okay. I
ask Allah subhana wa ta'ala to rectify
your affairs, deal with your trauma. And
if this man I haven't taken his word, I
I haven't heard his story. I don't know
nothing about him. You're the one who's
just talking. Okay? If he's oppressed
you, may Allah subhanaa tala deal with
him as him. And if he hasn't and you was
the rebellious one who was an ungrateful
woman and you cause divorce, whatever it
is, may Allah subhanaa allow you to
rectify that you don't do that in your
next marriage. Okay? But again, like I
said before, I'm doing this because I
hate to see divorces happening and I
hate to see people like this woman who
are encouraging divorces. Till next
time, asalam allayikum
from your day-to-day da bros misogynist.